hemos visto que si tenemos un entero
pensaremos que este círculo amarillo es
un entero y lo dividimos en cinco partes
iguales 1 2 3 4 5 puedo decir entonces
que tengo este entero con
cinco partes iguales estamos bien si yo
dibujo una de estas partes iguales en
color rojo tendré algo así
y entonces podré decir que tengo un
quinto así lo hemos conocido sin embargo
todo esto lo hemos visto desde las
formas desde un pay o podemos pensar en
una pizza o cosas por el estilo aunque
también lo podemos pensar desde una
recta numérica como un número netamente
y para eso haré una recta numérica
empezaremos en el cero y nuestra recta
numérica
será larga para que nosotros podamos ver
la dimensión de las cosas tenemos que
aquí tenemos el 1
y aquí tenemos el número dos si yo
buscará representar o localizar este un
quinto dentro de la recta numérica lo
que esto me está diciendo es que la
unidad o el entero digamos del 0 al 1
está dividido en cinco partes iguales
así es que dividiré esto en cinco partes
iguales veamos una
4 y 5 pensemos que estas son 5 partes
iguales si yo buscara representar de
estas 5 partes iguales el recorrido de
una
pues haré algo muy sencillo del 0 del 0
me moveré una posición hacia el 1
porque es una de las cinco posibles
partes iguales así es que aquí pondremos
entonces que tengo una de las cinco
partes en las que está dividido me
entero del 0 al 1 eso implicaría que
aquí también tengo dos quintos tres
quintos
cuatro quintos
cinco quintos
de hecho estos cinco quintos los podemos
ver como un entero
cinco quintos es igual a un entero y
esto tiene sentido si hacemos lo
siguiente si nosotros tenemos aquí un
quinto y es sólo una de las cinco partes
dibujadas
qué pasa si dibujo en rojo una segunda
parte de ellos
eso en nuestra gráfica se representaría
como una posición más hacia la derecha
hacia el 1 dos quintos 12 muy bien vamos
a dibujar tres quintos
tres de las cinco posibles piezas y eso
nos implicaría un movimiento hacia la
derecha tenemos 123 en rojo de las cinco
posibles y así estos serían cuatro
quintos
y cinco quintos porque tiene sentido que
cinco quintos sea uno entero porque si
ustedes se dan cuenta tenemos ahora todo
el entero o todo el círculo dibujado en
rojo tendremos entonces las cinco partes
iguales dibujadas en rojo como lo pueden
ver aquí y eso implica que tenemos todo
el entero o un entero completo dibujado
en rojo vamos a completar
los dos saltos que tenemos para tener el
entero completo y ustedes vean que nos
desplazamos cinco de esas partes iguales
hacia el uno del cero hasta el 1 en este
caso ya no tenemos sólo un quinto ahora
tenemos cinco quintos
lo que será igual a un entero
o si lo vemos en la recta numérica será
igual al número 1
nos vemos en otro vídeo